bonsoir madame reding bon cela remet ça
fonctionne bien
premier point que je vais aborder avec
vous il ya des mesures pour les années
dans ce qui a été annoncé aujourd'hui
notamment 500 dollars aux aînés de 75
ans et plus comme un chèque qui est
envoyé cet été est-ce que c'est pas une
manoeuvre une stratégie électorale pour
votre parti non absolument pas dans
notre budget on a un an c'est que on va
élargir à la subvention pour la vs pour
ce qui en soi en 15 ans et de plus et
avant de faire ça on va donner un peu
plus d'argent à nos aînés qui ont su
free beaucoup pendant la pandémie
je veux aussi souligner qu' on a déjà
dans l'énoncé à économique de l'automne
on a déjà dit que on va envoyer à une
1200 dollars aux familles avec tes petit
enfant alors que cet argent sera là pour
eux et je pense que c'est nécessaire
c'est toujours les nous avons attendu si
vous permettez en vrai sur les aînés
pourquoi 75
pourquoi pas à partir de 65 ans il ya
des aînés de 65 à 75 qui ont besoin de
sommes supplémentaires également nous
pensons que et les chiffres le
démontrent que c'est les années qui ont
plus de 75 ans qui en les besoins les
plus grandes
ils sont évidemment plus vieux il en
délit à l'argent qu'il en a peut-être
ils ont déjà dépensé de l'argent pour
devenir pour avoir 75 ans et il en plus
de besoins
alors assez pour cette raison qu'on
pense que c'est le groupe parmi les ege
qui a
plus besoin de l'être je regardais
aujourd'hui les données de l' ocde
le canada fait partie des pays qui
couvre le moins
les revenus de retraite on est quand
même très loin dans l' ocde et donc on
se demande pourquoi ne pas en faire
davantage pour les 65 ans et plus et ne
pas attendre à 75 ans parce que beaucoup
de gens qui arrivent à 65 ans et le
niveau de vie tombe à ce moment là chut
gérald c'est toujours possible de faire
du plu et non au gouvernement évidemment
à beaucoup de choses encore qu'on veut
faire mais je pense que pour les aînés
dans ce budget on inquiète et au cou il
ya des économistes qui affirme madame
freedom que vous n'avez pas à stimuler
l'économie
là le les dépenses vont augmenter avec
la fin de la pandémie
pourquoi vous tenez à injecter 100 101
milliards de plus sur trois ans mais
maintenant gérald je dois a souligné qu
il ya une contradiction entre vos
questions d'une côté vous me posez des
questions en demandant pourquoi on ne
fait pas de plus et d'autres côtés
est-ce qu'on fait trop occupé des
réponses on a trouvé un balancier et
concernant le 100 milliards de dollars
- je suis convaincu que avoir une
croissance économique avec des emplois
c'est une besoin urgente
il y a maintenant eu manque de 460
emplois au canada
on a besoin de croissance on a besoin
des emplois et ce budget va les créer
les garderies
est ce qu'on comprend que c'est le
système du québec que vous voulez mettre
en place partout au canada
oui
alors un système qui va se négocier
d'une province à l'autre et vous devrez
aussi avoir une nouvelle négociation
avec le québec
oui exactement et j'espère que tous les
experts du québec tous les féministes du
québec vont aider vont nous aider avec
des idées avec les constatations parce
que vraiment c'est le leadership du
québec à qui a démontré à tout le reste
pays ce qui est possible de faire
on comprend que tous vos programmes
dette vont très rapidement s'éteindre
d'ici l'automne dont vous continuer à
aider les canadiens mais on va fermer le
robinet si vous me permettez
l'expression d'ici l'automne ah oui al
nous avons quelques programmes qui vont
continuer une peuple ou à lézat supplice
manquent eux on a fait pour le système
d'assurance emploi va continuer pour une
en est aussi une programme qui va
commencer en juin pour aider les
entreprises à inviter des nouveaux
travailleurs ce programme va continuer
jusqu'à novembre
mais oui en pendant l'été et l'automne
on va passer du moment quand on va
appuyer les canadiens pendant la lutte
contre le coc vite et on va passer à la
relance complète la réouverture complète
de notre économie
alors les programmes économiques doivent
changer vous n'avez pas de cibles de
réduction de 2 de l'adepte du déficit
pas de cible de déficit zéro je
comprends que ces cours en même temps
parce qu'on part d'un gros déficit qu'il
faut l'amoindrir mais dans votre esprit
madame free run avez vous une cible de
déficit zéro je suis d'accord avec vous
que l'on doit un mot à dire et la dette
et le déficit et c'est ce que notre
budget et que nos projections démontre
la ddt
être comme un pourcentage pourcentage de
la pib va en décline dans la période
budgétaire est aussi le déficit va en
détenu est sera jusqu'à une vertu une
personne a dû mille d'un sec 20 6 alors
je suis d'accord avec vous on doit avoir
une des clés on aura et je veux
souligner la chose publique
une petite chose est ce parce que le
temps nous est compté on ne se donne un
temps limite donc pas de 17,0 pas de
cible de déficit zéro
à on devra et on aura une des clés dans
la dette est dans le déficit
la chose la plus importante c'est la
croissance avec la croissance économique
avec une économie forte
c'est la manière dont là que c'est la
chose qui lui permettra de payer nos
dettes
c'est le temps que nous avons merci
madame claude ok merci beaucoup géré
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit